everybody hates the AK sound and CS2 but
I feel like spoiler everyone has always
hated the AK sounds in CS So today we're
going to react and see how bad it
actually is
it's honestly pretty good but I feel
like the reason it's pretty good is
because the old sound and CS go was just
that bad
this has never sounded good it's never
sounded nearly as good as the old CS go
sound this is a very bottom tier bottom
bottom bottom tier AK sound
this was so much better why did valve
get rid of this this was so much better
the goat dude this is a [__] core
memory bro yo you guys remember in
middle school coming home loading up 1.6
and I believe if memory serves it
sounded exactly the same in Source I
think it just had a slightly different
signature
bro I don't remember it sounding this
good in Source maybe because I hate
source so much